hi I'm and Blanchard I am I work at
parsley I'm a back back in software
engineer there and i'm here to talk to
you today about simple reliable parallel
processing with python and storm using
stream parts and pie storm so just
throwing out lots of you know proper
nouns at you just to keep you on your
toes so as most of us are well aware
python has this lovely thing called the
global interpreter lock or the gill
which makes it so that you can't
actually run two pieces of interpreted
python code at the same time in the same
interpreter so even if you use multi
threading it won't actually gain you any
performance benefits unless you're one
of your threads is waiting for i 0 if
you're trying to do to see po2 cpu-bound
things at the same time you're out of
luck on multi-core it can actually even
make your performance worse then your
cinco threaded application that should
be fixed in python I think 3.2 or 3.3 I
can't whichever the one they rewrote the
gillan but for Python 2 if you're stuck
on 2.7 that is really awful anyway my
lovely boss Andrew mantle NT discuss
this in more detail this afternoon if
anybody went to his talk was lit I think
I was at one o'clock but moving on so
the standard way that most people try to
solve the problem of the gill with a
large production system where you're
trying to do lots of things in parallel
is by using a queue and worker system
where you have a Cuba you know sits
there and fills up with jobs and then it
sends the jobs out to the workers so
most people who do this use things like
zeromq and Retta sand rabbitmq and cron
jobs and our queue and celery and all
that I say this because before my time
at my time at parsley this is what the
architecture used to look at parsley in
2012 it was kind of a mess with all the
workers and queues and things feeding
into each other and it you know they
thankfully before I came they
did that that was really messy and it
was it was time to try to move on from
that so it was around you know that time
that they heard about this thing called
storm like you know what is this so it's
a the tagline is that it's a distributed
real-time computation system and so you
know if you read that you go okay what
does that mean the basic idea is it can
allow you to really simplify your setup
of workers and queues and it's pythons
support out of the box is not the best
but it does allow you to add support for
basically any other language to storm
pretty easily through this thing called
multilang protocol which we'll talk
about later and so what we've done at
parsley is there's a project
healthstream parse and now there's a
sort of offshoot of that called pie
storm that are here to try to make
working with storm with python much
simpler so as a bit of background i
should mention what we're actually using
storm for and so parsley is a web
contact and web content analytics
platform for major publishing companies
so that's just a small list of our
customers there are many more and
basically what we do is we provide these
really nice dashboards for editors and
writers to look at every day that's two
of them things like you know how many
views or minutes of engaged time or you
know what are the most popular articles
on the site who are the most popular
authors that kind of thing and you know
editors and publishers love that because
it allows them to actually get an idea
of you know where they should be
spending their money as far as you know
what are the kinds of stories they can
do that will actually help them make
some ad revenue to stay afloat we also
provide some powerful data API s so that
people can do recommendations and things
like that so like the New Yorkers you
might like thing
uses the parsley API under the hood to
recommend pages you might like so that's
a lot of data that we deal with because
we have so many publishers you know
we're talking billions of page views
we're dealing with every month so one of
the common things you hear from people
is that well you know python can't do
this yeah it can't scale it's just a toy
language is the kind of thing you'll
hear from Java people about this kind of
stuff and or should he use Scala was 11
that Mike here occasionally but we found
that using storm and Python together
we've it's kind of hard to see that on
this display but basically what this is
showing is that this is like H top
running on three different servers and
every core is lit up pretty much a
hundred percent all from Python
processes running in parallel using
stream cars and that's all thanks to
storm so stream parts is basically what
allows you to do pythonic storm it lets
you parse real-time streams of data
which is the idea behind the name it
smoothly integrates Python code with
storm and it's got some nice tools for
getting started and it's heavily
production tested and I was wondering
why my animations weren't working but so
it decided to work on that one bullet so
that's also um it's good for lots of low
latency stuff like analytics of logs and
sensor data so in the in the stock
basically I'm going to outline some
basic concepts behind storm and
typologies talk a little bit about the
internals because it's kind of
interesting and then talk about how we
actually get Python to work with storm
talk about house how you know stream
parts kind of came about and what the
state of things are and where we're
going next and if you want to follow
along at home I the slides are available
at the URLs listed there it's basically
parsley / slide / by storm 2015 so the
basic concepts behind storm so storm has
these abstractions for data processing
the
primarily we've got the tuple which is
like a little chunk of data and you've
got spouts which produce these tuples or
chunks of data bolts which take the
tuples and process them in some way and
then you've got topologies which are how
everything connects all together so as
an example with this wired topology you
can see that we've got you know a spout
over here that's producing some tuples
these little lines represent the streams
of tuples that are connected to
different bolts executors because you
can have many different copies of the
same bolts running at once and you know
running on multiple machines to keep up
with the flow and bolts can even feed
into other bolts it's not so you can
have a very complex topology the basic
idea behind the tuples is just like a
Python duple it's just a simple list of
data you know sequence of data i guess
not list right and so in the first one
we have is basically just a tuple that
contains words and the second one is a
tuple that contains words and counts the
reason I'm using words and counts is
because the word count topology is like
the example you see everywhere for
getting started with storm and things
like that it's just everyone loves to
talk about word counting probably
because it's a really simple thing to
you know that will fit on a slide so a
spout as i said is just a component that
emits raw data into the cluster and what
we have here is the actual code that
free using stream parse to implement a
simple spout that will produce an
endless sequence of words granted
they're just dog cat zebra and elephant
over and over and over again but you
know it's a sequence of words
nonetheless as you can see it's it's
pretty short and sweet you know we've
got this initialized method that's for
you know setting up connections to
databases or initializing things like
that so in this case we're just setting
up this itertools cycle but in a real
spout you might like have something
that's you know connecting to some sort
of data store then you also need to
implement
next to pool which is basically what
storm keeps calling over and over and
over again to get the next tuple and
that emits the tuple on one of the
streams and then a simple word counting
bolts we have here again we have
something that we're initializing here
the simple you know counter and then
there's a process method that you need
to implement that takes a tuple and does
something with it in this case where you
can see that we can access the values by
name which is something new in newer
versions of string parts and storm you
used to have to do everything by index
and so you'd have to keep track of like
what index is all of your fields were
and that was really irritating so we get
a word we increment the counter and then
we just log that just for debugging and
one of the things that's you might be
thinking about this is like well if
you're doing this all in parallel how
are these counter is going to stay in
sync and everything so this this
particular implementation relies on
something called a fields grouping and
so i'll show you how you set that up so
this is the current way in stream parse
that you'll set up an actual storm
topology is a storm topology is just a
directed acyclic graph that connects you
know the spouts and the bolts together
you used to have to write really a
gnarly closure a code and teach you
write your layout your topology which I
was not a fan of and so when I took over
as the maintainer of stream parse I
tried to make getting rid of that really
high on my list of things to do so I am
happy to say that now you can write
something really nice like this where
you basically the classes that you've
implanted before like the spouts and
bolts they have the special class method
that spec where you can pass the options
that you want through the topology so in
this case the power equals two means we
want to have to it this is describing
the parallel ISM for this component so
we
at least two not at least we want
exactly two executors for this spout and
then the word count bolt has
parallelisms set to eight so they'll be
eight of these running somewhere on your
cluster this inputs dictionary here maps
from the source to what kind of grouping
you want to use and so here we're using
a fields grouping and we're grouping on
the word field which means that any time
a word is emitted by this spout it will
basically be hashed and then that will
determine which one of the bolts
downstream it goes to if you know since
there's eight of these executors or the
word count bolt only one of them will
ever get instances of a particular word
so that way the count will be accurate
because we're just basically keeping
track of one well not one word but you
know particular subset of words that eat
it for each executor so to kind of some
all that up the way things look for the
word spout and the this counting boat we
have the spout doesn't take any sort of
input expla as far as the topology is
concerned whereas the bolts takes input
from the spout and the spout is
outputting to the count full whereas the
count Bowl isn't outputting anywhere the
types of tuples that we're going to see
from them for the words bad it's just
words and then the account bowl that's
words and counts and you can see that
we've got this word fields grouping
again on the word spout but we didn't
explicitly set up anything downstream
from the counting bolt but if we did the
default grouping is what's called the
shuffle grouping and where it just picks
a random executor every time so no
particular instance of anything down the
stream would get the tuples from this
and again we had the parallelism such a
two in h respectively so
to sort of briefly talk about how storm
performs its magic there's this thing
called the coupole tree and that's a
little blurry unfortunately but the way
it's it makes sure that everything is
reliable is that every time there's a
tuple emitted through the topology it
keeps their each component along the way
is supposed to like send a special
message a knack message back to the
storm the head like the master node is
called the Nimbus node so it sounds like
a message back to nimbus saying i have
finished processing this particular
tuple or i have failed at processing and
so as that's going along it builds this
tree of how far along a particular tool
has been processed so here you can see a
bunch of words and here's words and
counts so this is kind of give you a
basic idea what a tuple tree would look
like if something goes wrong along the
way a storm will automatically try and
have your spout replay a particular
tuple so that way it can you know try to
pick things up pick pick up where things
were before and hopefully whatever that
issue was was just an ephemeral thing
that'll go away but either way it keeps
track of the state of like every tuple
its processed so as I mentioned the
master node is runs a process called
Nimbus and then the other nodes on your
cluster would be worker nodes and and
worker nodes typically have a supervisor
process and then much a worker processes
and the worker processes are what are
actually going to run the instances of
your particular spouts or bolts the
supervisor just makes sure that if one
of these processes dies a new one gets
created and it also keeps in touch with
Nimbus to let Nimbus know that this
particular machine hasn't gone down
because if you have a if you have a big
enough cluster and you lose a machine
storm is actually smart enough to say oh
well that one's off so send all the work
over here instead and so it's really
nice for providing high availability the
master node and Nimbus also provides
something called the storm UI which is
just a web view that lets you kind of
see the state of the cluster and it's
really
it's pretty nice you can click around
and see logs and all sorts of stuff like
that since everyone has internet
troubles at this particular conference I
did not make anything actually clickable
and they say in this presentation so
when you when you start up your cluster
you're just going to end up with a whole
bunch of empty slots on the on the
machines that are just waiting for work
and once you submit your topology to
nimbus it's going to start actually
filling in the slots on those nodes and
you can end up in a state where you've
got all of the processes for a
particular topology all on like one
machine just by bad luck if you've
submitted like a whole bunch of
topologies it might just be like that
that's where the particular open spaces
were at a given time so one of the nice
things that storm has is this
rebalancing command where you say
rebalance and it shifts everything
around and make sure that there's like
an equal number of processes for each
topology spread throughout the cluster
as a quick aside if you're going to use
storm you should use this book because
storm flight is a fantastic reference
for stroke for using storm it doesn't
have much about specifics with Python
but Andrew actually wrote the foreword
for it so we endorse it heavily it
parsley I'm not actually going to go
into the details of this particular
slide but if you you know are following
along at home and want to read this in
detail this is basically laying out how
storm does some really fancy stuff to
make sure that it doesn't run into
network throughput issues and how it
detects like if it's running into
problems sending messages to a
particular note how it shifts them to
somebody else so to sum up storm is
pretty amazing it guarantees processing
views tuple trees it allows tuning how
much parallelism you want per component
in the topology it's highly available
and it allocates actual you know python
process slots on physical nodes can
rebalance things when things go a little
wonky and it handles high throughput
network messaging of automatically
because of all this it you know we can
use this to sidestep to go so let's try
to set something up so we get in a
situation like this so to actually get
Python on storm we had to implement
something called the multilang protocol
it it is basically a simple JSON
protocol that works via these shell
based components so in the Java and
there's a thing called a shell spout in
a show bolt that Java has running bet
keep a pipe open to a Python subprocess
and so they just keep talking they send
messages to each other so anytime you
know there's a tuple incoming it first
has to go through the Java shall show
boat like parent process and then it
goes to the Python process so yeah they
communicate over standard ensena it's
kind of you know unix see way of doing
it but it's also pretty clean the nice
thing about the way this works is we can
use we can use C Python or pipe I we
don't have to use like Jai thon or pie
for Jay I know if anyone here is try to
use spark before but using pie for Jay
with spark can be painful at times
because if something goes wrong you get
some sort of horrible weird java error
that you have no idea how your code
because it could have possibly caused
this to happen I speak from experience
like pulling my hair out trying to solve
one of those problems for a while so
this is nice because we can just use
regular Python and talk two things over
pipes and storm has pretty extensive
logs and we have extensive logging on
the stream far side so if something goes
wrong you can pretty easily pinpoint
where it went wrong but it is a little
bit of a quirky protocol but it's not
too hard to implement so as I mentioned
there's the shell spouts and she'll
bolts and they talk two things via
standard and centered out using JSON one
thing I want to mention is that in
recent versions of storm they've added
support for doing this serialization
they made the plot the serialization
pluggable so you don't have to use JSON
anymore it's just the person who's
written the multi lying
for your language must have also
implemented you know whatever a protocol
you want to use so and in our case up
until very recently there was nothing
that supported anything other than JSON
on the Python end as far as talking to
multilang is concerned but in a the
upcoming version of stream virus we're
adding support for message back which
was first developed by well I'll get
into that later anyway so there's one
sub process / storm task and so if we
set the parallels in eight we end up
with eight Python processes so you never
have the issue where there's Python
threads it play there's also some nice
extra stuff that if you want to make a
really fancy topology when the
connection between Java and Python gets
up there's this handshake that gets sent
which has a bunch of information about
the topology like what are the things
that are feeding into your component
what are the things that are reading
from your component you know you can
even store settings for your bolts
inside there's like a big config file
basically that storm keeps track up for
each topology and so you can put your
own custom stuff in there and it's a
nice way to be able to distribute
settings to all of your components it
also recently added support for heart
beats so if the subprocesses get stuck
that'll be detected if you're using
storm earlier than zero point nine point
three they did not used to be detected
so you could end up that with a really
awful state where it looked like
everything was fine with your topology
but for some reason it just wasn't doing
anything so that was that was a great
addition recently so there's this thing
called stormed up PI that's bundled with
storm and as a you know newbie to storm
you might be tempted to go okay well
storm comes with this thing why I don't
even need stream parser any of this
stuff well it's and not to be confused
with pie storm which is something
come in a minute it's not at all
pythonic and its really unreliable they
there there's like no error handling at
all in it it is just it's um it was
written by a bunch of people who didn't
know how to write Python you know it was
it was written as an example very early
on in the project by a bunch of Java
developers and it looks and reads and
acts like that they also have a ruby one
you know I don't know if that's any
better but you know that the example
ones I give I think we're really
intended as an examples but people
started trying to use them in production
and that wasn't really a great thing so
you know parsley we thought well you
know we should fix this we should make
it so there's a decent implementation
for Python so it'd be nice to be able to
treat storm as an infrastructure like
how even though Cassandra and elastic
search and things like that or written
in Java a lot of people here use them
because they have really nice pythonic
api's you can use to access them so
Python needs to be you know a first
class citizen for this and you know one
of the things when you're submitting a
topology to storm it has to be in a jar
and all that so you know it'd be really
nice if we could wrap a lot of that so
you didn't have to worry about how to
put that jar together so now I'm going
to talk more about stream parts and how
we sort of solve some of these problems
so the initial release was in april 2014
it's had over a year of very active
development we've got updated this
number day over 800 * sanket of a it was
much lower before and it was a trending
repository in May 2014 we've got a lot
of active mailing list members and we're
up to 13 non Pursley committers and
there are three parsley engineers myself
included who are maintaining it I'm the
primary person these days and we've even
got funding from darpa to keep
maintaining it which is nice I I think
for like another year that's supposed to
continue so if you click that link you
can see the project description and
suffer why they're funding this so
after stream parts came out it was only
a matter of months later I think this
may be like five months later that
yelped came out with a single pile eous
which is there a Python storm library
and you know they're each take different
approaches to handling some of the
problems with packaging and how you
should describe your topology and stuff
like that so I think there's a place for
both of them just depends on your
particular preferences but the part that
doesn't make any sense is that we're
both implementing the at one part of our
projects is we're both implementing the
exact same protocol this multi lying
protocol there's really only one way to
do with correctly and we both wrote the
same code independently like if you did
a diff on it it's almost identical so we
should really just have one Python
implementation of multi line because any
time the add new features this protocol
like why should two different sets of
developers have to go in and update it
and make then test it and all that just
seems like a giant waste of resources so
enter pie storm what pie storm is is
there was a sub package inside stream
force inside stream parts that handled
the the IPC stuff and I split that out
into its own project I even made it in a
separate organization on github so it
doesn't look like it's owned by parsley
it's just you know pie storm / by storm
on github and then I took the PI lius
serialization code which was the only
thing that they had that was different
from us and I put that in there and so
it's like completely backward compatible
for their end and then I submitted an
issue to them and said like hey why
don't we work together on this uh be
great and I heard nothing but you know
I'm hoping that eventually you know I
think you know people get busy right so
they're probably just busy I totally get
what being busy is like I'm not trying
like publicly shame the more anything by
bringing this up I'm just saying you
know hopefully someday they'll get
around to responding to that issue and I
would really like to see this replace
stormed up you I in the Apache project
I I also know that the main developers
of storm would also like to see this
replace stormed up ey because they don't
want to keep maintaining it because they
you know they don't know python so
hopefully we'll get there but we're not
there yet so i guess i should mention so
right now the in development version of
stream parts it has a dependency on pi
storm instead of just having its own
copy of it so i might you know i
mentioned stream parts in pi storm kind
of like almost interchangeably in this
chalk but but pi storm is basically just
the sub section that deals with multi
line directly and then stream bars has a
bunch of extra stuff on top of that so
stream parse provides this command line
interface called sparse or s parse
that's a front-end and you can install
it with pip you can solve this whole
thing with Pip and annoyingly right now
you need this other dependency that's
not pippin solved will called line again
which is a like a closure thing but once
you have that setup you can just run
sparse quick start and I'll give you an
example project that just runs the is a
word count topology and you can run it
by running sparse run you'll see a ton
of debug output like there's this box
should go down to here and then have dot
dot dots after it i guess but don't make
it too obnoxious we can see an example
of this over here in a gift it's a
little hard to see but basically you
know they ran sparse quick start they're
running it you can see over here there's
some process monitoring so you can see
the java stuff started up right now it's
compiling the topology which takes a
little while because you know java and
compiling and then for a second here
you'll see some python processes all pop
out once things actually start to happen
so you can see there's a bunch of python
processes and then unfortunately the
gift loops but but so when we run
sparsit so so to run that that will run
it locally right so this is for
debugging there's like a local topology
mode where you're running it all on your
machine you can see everything there
if something goes wrong you can very
pretty easily track it down if you want
to actually run something in production
you need to submit the topology to
nimbus and so the sparse submit command
is a bunch of stuff for you it'll make
virtual land ends on all the worker
nodes in your cluster that have all the
dependencies your topology needs this is
optional though we recently made this
optional because some people were in
situations were like you know they
didn't have ssh access to the boxes that
though were submitting to the only port
that was open was the Nimbus one and so
they you know they said that we're going
to manage our dependencies on our own is
there some way that you can make it so
you guys stop trying to install stuff
through ssh and having it keep failing
so we added that and then after that it
builds a jar especially like formatted
jar with your code in the right
directory for to make storm happy it
tunnels into Nimbus and then it
constructs an in-memory topology spec
and then it uploads everything to nimbus
so that's a lot of stuff to have to do
yourself it's a nice step just be able
to run one command enough to deal with
it one other thing we provide is thing
called the batching bolt so in this case
this is using a couple new features but
you can specify config options to the
topology like this now and so this is
talking about how tick tuples so one
thing that they added in storm is okay
five minutes tick tuples are basically
tuples that come every so many seconds
so you can set the frequency in second
so if you want to have something
time-based going on the cleanest way to
do it without having to actually add
threading and a bunch of stuff to your
code which is kind of the whole thing
you're trying to avoid in the first
place is using tick two pools and so
it's just a guarantee that your your
you'll keep getting a tuple every so
many seconds so this says that we're
going to batch things up in the for
every five seconds that goes by we're
going to create a batch
and we're going to group things in two
batches based on words and then we'll
process that batch of words that once so
we're we're going to determine how many
words were in this particular batch is
all this simple bolt us so this is 5
second micro batches and the reason you
might actually use this in real life is
if you've got some sort of crazy etl
topology where you're you know doing a
bunch of transformations on your data
from a source and then eventually you
want to load it into a data store which
is what we do it parsley so we you know
we get the raw data from I'm not going
to go through the whole infrastructure
but basically we get raw data and then
we do a bunch of transformations on it
and then we store it an elastic search
in the end if we were just you know
hammering elasticsearch sending it like
individual document updates when we're
processing millions of documents you
know every minute that would be crazy
and it would be really really slow so
instead we have a batching bolt that you
know batches things every so many
seconds and sends one big request to
elasticsearch at a time which it's much
happier with databases don't like to be
hammered like that so stream porous and
pie storm sort of completely replace
your need for using stormed up you I
there's a whole list of like kind of
snarky things on here so I don't need to
go through them all there it's just
reiterating stuff I already said before
basically the config files we have oh
right I have a microphone right there
the config files we have lighted even
set up multiple environments so if you
have like a vagrant vm maybe on your
machine for testing stuff out you could
have that set up as one of an
environment with a Nimbus stored in
vagrant and then you might have another
one that's an environment that's
actually like your production
environment so you can do sparse submit
to the each of these environments
separately pretty easily there are a ton
of commands first bar snow I didn't have
time to mention all of them some of the
New Orleans that are nice let you get
stats about the topology you know the
running cluster and find out what your
logs look like and stuff like that more
exciting stuff is what's coming soon so
we're trying to simplify the deployment
process so currently we were creating
all these virtual lems via SSH
optionally but we still that's how we
handle dependencies that doesn't work at
all for docker because people can't
associate SSH into docker containers
typically considering that they tell you
to never enable ssh and a doctor
container so what we're going to try to
do instead is set it up so that once the
topology actually starts up it's going
to then run this like one-time process
that sets up your virtual lens the
python topology dsl i showed you I'm
almost done I've identified topology dsl
I showed is is basically finished but
it's not actually available in a release
yet so the nice clean thing I showed you
is in this pull request if you want to
follow it I also remove all traces of
closure from our code and that should be
pretty easy because we can use thrift to
communicate with Nimbus go storm was
designed to use the rift but we weren't
doing that before because thrift I
didn't exist and thrift pie is a really
really nice thrift implementation for
python that is much nicer than the
official one because it works for Python
3 and you don't have to compile anything
to use it because it's all pure python
they can parse through files and
purified and then we're going to add
message pack serialization from the pile
ease people and are there any questions
can be squeezed won't do it yeah no
question okay